180.000 personas han sido evacuadas de
sus hogares en las regiones fronterizas
de India y Pakistán bautizada con el
nombre de Viper Jovi que significa
desastre en bengalí la tormenta tropical
alcanzó Vientos de 125 kilómetros por
hora en su punto más álgido este jueves
aunque se ha debilitado 900 pueblos
quedaron sin electricidad después de que
la tormenta derribara líneas eléctricas
en la provincia India de guajar la
ministra pakistaní de cambio climático
declaró en Twitter que su país se había
Librado en gran medida de los vientos ya
que la ciudad de carachi con 20 millones
de habitantes sólo quedó en los bordes
del ciclón sin embargo la prensa local
informó que debido al mal drenaje las
aguas residuales inundaron las
carreteras de varios distritos de la
ciudad de mir purkas en el interior de
karachi cine es una de las ciudades de
Pakistán a una afectadas por las
devastadoras inundaciones de 2022 en las
que murieron más de 1700 personas
India por su parte sigue en el punto de
mira de la tormenta y se prevé que se
desplace al noreste hacia el estado
interior de rajastán donde ya se han
registrado Fuertes lluvias este es solo
el comienzo de la temporada de ciclones
en el mar arábigo los ciclones derivan
su energía del calor en el mar y en la
atmósfera cuando más caliente más
potente será la tormenta se necesita una
temperatura mínima de 26,5 grados
centígrados para que se forme un ciclón
Y a medida que la temperatura aumente en
todo el mundo estos fenómenos
meteorológicos podrían generalizarse